well testing has become a priority not
just for the Trump administration but
for the healthcare community at large
with the need for testing kits comes a
rise in fake kits from those looking to
profit on fear US Customs and Border
Protection seizing a shipment of fake
kovat 19 kits at Los Angeles Airport two
weeks ago then another shipment at
Chicago's O'Hare Airport last week all
were due to be purchased by desperate
Americans wondering if they have
coronavirus adding the possibility of a
false negative result and it becomes
important know what a true testing kit
is dr. Schott Nasiri is a beverly hills
ENT with 20 years of experience and he's
also a Harvard Medical School graduate
dr. Nasir thank you for joining us I
mean we look at these reports of bogus
tests how do you know if these things
are legit right the first question
always is thank you so much for having
me on tonight and we stand together as a
nation facing this horrible pandemic the
first question always is if something
seems too good to be true it probably is
though I mean Keith anzan at heart
everything is pretty much
straightforward so if no one in the
country can really get adequate testing
and we're so far behind the eight-ball
in terms of adequately testing most of
our citizens and you get a kit in the
mail for 250 or 300 dollars it's gonna
attendee in 15 minutes with a tremendous
accuracy you know that's just not really
the case right now yeah and that's the
thing is you see some of these tests
doctor and I hate to interrupt you there
but a little bit of delay on skype you
see some of these tests out there and
you think you know you hear about these
things oh yeah just put saliva on the
stick put it in the thing and then ten
minutes later you got it how do we know
I mean physically how do you know that
you're doing the tests properly so for
I'm start to finish you want to see that
it has the right type of swab and this
is the universal UTM swab it's a Dacron
or a plastic swab not the kind of swab
test we use for doing normal bacterial
cultures in the office
where we'll often times check for strep
throat but these are the plastic ones
unfortunately they're manufactured
mostly in Italy which is why there's
also kind of an
and wider regional shortage in the
northern hemisphere for these swabs and
then when a doctor checks you if they're
doing it and they're very experienced
with it they're gonna be checking not
just the front of your nose they're
gonna be going from the front of your
nose and when I tell my patients I say
this is gonna be the most unpleasant
nose swab ever done on you we go from
the front of the nose where there's a
pretty good concentration of virus
particles to the very back about three
and a half inches in so basically we
meet where nose meets the throat where
it feels like almost I met your tonsils
through your nose and that's the highest
concentration of virus for almost every
respiratory virus whether that be the
flu influenza and studies from the CDC
show the tests that we have in our
office if we just swab the front of the
nose they'll pick up if there are four
people in a room with influenza they'll
pick up at best three because you're
still gonna miss what's called sampling
error it's like going into a school and
seeing the first of five classrooms and
you test the first room the closest to
the door you're not gonna get the most
accurate sample of how many classrooms
are full yeah
same it knows if you're checking in the
mouth or buccal mucosa the the shed of
the virus is substantially reduced
compared to that in the nose so that's
number one number two is what kind of
test is it and most physicians I'm a
surgeon so we do a lot of tests that are
specific and necessary so when we're
checking we're checking the gold
standard the gold standard the
rolls-royce of most of this kind of test
is called PCR polymerase chain reaction
that everyone's familiar with from crime
scene investigators like we see 50
copies of DNA from any virus anyone's
blood sample and we can amplify that
with the PCR or a chain reaction and
find a virus or someone's DNA so that's
different levels of PCR the newest
testing by quest Diagnostics which is
pretty much the largest lab in the
country LabCorp
and then there are hand
of other really solid platforms like
Becton Dickinson has one bio fire
the newest one that got approval is
Sofia CEP HDI the bread things they
don't they don't mean a lot to people
because they're not riding him down here
doctor I want to get let me get your
opinion if I can on kind of moving
forward because dr. deborah birx was
talking about testing used as both
diagnostic and surveillance I'm gonna
play her somebody and then get your
response on the other side the important
thing about testing it only tells you if
you're positive or negative that day you
could become positive the next day and
so testing should be used intentionally
as a surveillance tool or a diagnostic
tool and I think what we're gonna work
on over the weekend is to weave together
both a testing strategy for surveillance
which you have brought up in that key
point while maintaining a strong testing
for diagnosis because our first
obligation is still to ensure that
patients get diagnosed testing for
surveillance and diagnostic what does
that mean to you as an ENT right so if
someone's been exposed to corona virus
let's say your daughter has it your
neighbor has it your mother has it and
most people will manifest just like
getting exposed to the flu between about
the fourth or fifth day and about the
tenth day all the way out to 14 days but
95% of people will live within that bell
curve where the fourth day to the tenth
day will see that they're going to turn
up positive and have symptoms within a
day or two of symptoms almost everyone
has the highest yield for that kind of
test if it's the PCR if it's another
type of test that's when your that's
when you get your money's worth so to
speak so that's the diagnostic testing
because otherwise if you test in the
first three or four days it's going to
be negative and then out later you're
gonna get pick up a smaller proportion
of people but that sweet spot is that
middle kind of eight to ten days where
you're gonna find it diagnostically dr.
nasarah I got to go but I want to ask
you very quickly are we getting faster
at these test results I mean it seems to
me like we're getting better at this
stuff unfortunate
with with the gold standard test like
the PCR it still takes a solid day or
two the new wear machine that our
automated can do a result within a day
but the truly fast ones can do a
turnaround within an hour but it's still
transporting the tests is there not
point-of-care yet transporting the test
from the person to the laboratory and
then getting it in the queue to run it
and each machine can only run so many
per hour so it's still gonna take at
least a day in almost all parts of the
country yeah Wow dr. Nasir incredibly
good information sir thank you so much
for coming on we appreciate it it's my
pleasure trace